Hey everybody it's charlie this is going
to be my new spider-man 3 marvel video
there were a couple websites that were
reporting an actual title
for spider-man 3 so we'll break it down
we also have an official casting
description for the main villain that
reads exactly like a major sinister six
character
and there's a bunch of updates for venom
two the morbius movie you know marvel
and sony are planning on crossing tom
hall and spider-man over with the venom
movies in the sony verse in future
movies
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a giveaway right now for the new
marvel avengers game all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know how you want them to cross
spiderman over with venom in the movies
so just starting with the big stuff
first number five the new title so
recently on a couple of major websites
fans noticed that an actual title for
spider-man 3 had been listed instead of
the standard
untitled spider-man movie sequel the way
it leaked out was very similar to the
way that the title for avengers
end game leaked out last year if you
guys remember before marvel officially
revealed the title the cinematographer
of the movie
updated his website with his credits to
include avengers endgame but it was
before marvel had announced avengers 4
was called avengers end game so post all
your iron man avengers memes
he thought we wouldn't notice but we did
that was months before the end game
title reveal
so this past week a bunch of users
noticed that both esquire and maxim
two major brands not just small blog
websites are now reporting the title of
spider-man 3
is spider-man homesick so i guess r.i.p
copywriter who probably wasn't supposed
to leak that
press f in the chat his job died so that
we could see this out in the wild
tom holland could not be reached for
comment i'm mostly surprised that the
news didn't come from him
since they kind of used him to leak all
this information there was also news
from the set of spider-man 3. right now
they're building the sets for the actual
movie getting ready to film later this
year after tom holland finishes filming
the uncharted movie that's right there
is an uncharted nathan drake movie
in reportedly on set the crew is
referring to spider-man 3
as spider-man homesick seemingly
confirming what these websites are
saying
still not confirmed by marvel officially
so you have to take it with a grain of
salt but if it's coming from a couple of
different places it sounds a little more
legit
homesick as a title makes sense just
because where they left things in the
spiderman far from home post credit
scene he is now
number one most wanted on everyone's hit
list
both the villains and the heroes are
after him every law enforcement agency
on the planet
so home is the last place that he could
go that's exactly where they're going to
look for him
there were a lot of spider-man homeless
memes earlier but i guess that title is
just too depressing
i'm actually kind of glad that it's not
spider-man home run that was one of my
early favorites but the whole reason why
you'd call a spider-man movie home run
would be to make that baseball metaphor
and in baseball a home run is only
earned after you round four bases
sony has already confirmed that they
have plans to make spider-man 4 with tom
holland and marvel
so they're still free to use home run is
the title of spider-man 4.
and i'll talk more about sinister six in
a second too because number four
apparently the new casting breakdown
that's being reported for the main
villain
definitely sounds like a sinister six
team member the casting description just
reads that marvel studios is looking for
a joel kinnaman
type for an untitled spider-man sequel
which is effectively spider-man 3.
now which sinister 6 villain major
villain do you think that joel kenneman
could be but craven the hunter he
doesn't really come off as a doctor
octopus even though i would love to see
a new mcu version of doctor octopus
but just to be clear just because the
casting description says a joel kinnaman
type
doesn't mean that they're actually
trying to cast joel kinnaman himself
they just want someone with his vibe
talking about super deep spider-man cuts
joe manginello said a while ago that it
would be his dream to come back into the
spider-man movies and play craven
well so as a comic book reader one of my
favorite
favorite comic book stories of all time
that's so dark and
twisted and unique is craven's last hunt
oh yeah that's that one is it's it's
maddening
it's insane and um and what it what an
amazing ending and
and great turn um so i mean that's
that's one of those that i i would be
they have to
they're going to have to make that it's
too good of a story so craven's
apparently going to get a solo movie
but in the same vein that venom is where
it's not in the marvel cinematic
universe yeah they still want a marvel
cinematic universe craven
well you have to have him cross over at
some point because if
you i mean craven's last hunt is too
good a piece of material it's about it's
like
you know it's like um wolverine the
frank miller japanese wolverine like
you're killing jokes you can't not tell
that story yeah is that a role you would
go for if given the opportunity for sure
well craven yeah you kidding me that
would be like a dream
the really cool thing about him is that
if you don't remember he actually played
flash thompson in the tobey maguire
spider-man movies
and from what we've seen in the morbius
trailer already sony and marvel are
mixing and matching a lot of easter eggs
from different eras in spider-man movies
so it'd be a really cool easter egg for
him to come back
but that doesn't necessarily confirm
anything but more to craven in the mcu
just in general last year during the
spider-man far from home press tour the
director
john watts said that if he got the
chance to come back for spider-man 3
he would want to use craven the hunter
is one of the next big villains and they
confirmed that he was coming back a
little while ago
so i would say odds are pretty good that
craven will be one of if not the main
villain of spider-man 3.
sony is also still developing a craven
solo movie is part of their venom
spin-off movies just like morbius
no idea when that movie would happen but
if sony wants craven and marvel wants
craven we're probably going to see him
show up pretty soon
but even more sinister 6 number 3
michael mando who plays the scorpion
teased a little while ago that he'd be
coming back into the spider-man movies
soon he didn't say which movie he be
coming back for or if he'd be coming
back for multiple
cameos or just one movie but getting
into bigger sinister six setup and
teasers
we almost have a full sinister six team
in the mcu right now if you include
craven
these villains that we now have in our
universe happen to be characters
that are in the sinister six there may
be something that happens with that no
matter where he goes
the world is going to be different for
him here's the real blockbuster
brace yourselves you might want to sit
out spider-man's name is
peter parker what the f
no more hiding yeah no more hiding and
if you're thinking about crossing things
over with the venomverse why would the
vulture
major sinister six character show up in
his white prison uniform from the
spider-man homecoming post-credits scene
if sony weren't trying to imply that
venom and the other sony spider-verse
characters would also be involved in
future sinister six movies
we've already known about tom hall and
spider-man crossing over with tom
hardy's venom for a while now it's just
a question of when that's going to
happen
right now it's been reported that sony
wants tom holland to have a small cameo
scene in venom 2
no word on venom possibly cameoing
during spider-man 3. but it seems like
spider-man 3
will just be similar to spider-man
homecoming and spider-man far from home
in that they're really just going to be
one major sinister six villain and a
couple smaller villains in the
background
and from what we've seen from venom 2 so
far let there be carnage they're mostly
just focusing on cletus cassidy getting
the carnage symbiote and fighting venom
without doing any really huge spider-man
tom hall and stuff till
maybe potentially a post-credit scene
and since sony announced they're doing
spider-man 4 eventually with marvel
again renewing that sharing deal one
more time and kevin feige said that he
didn't have any big plans to be doing
a venom spider-man movie in the mcu it
sounds like the venom spider-man
crossover will be a pure sony movie
so number two early prediction
spider-man 4 winds up being
spider-man home run and they do it as
their spider-man vs the sinister 6 movie
and then spider-man vs venom is a
totally separate movie that sony does
on their own with tom holland there were
reports a while ago about tom holland
supposedly signing another new contract
for even more
marvel and spider-man movies that would
cover the bigger crossovers in bigger
future avengers movies like avengers 5
and then avengers secret wars even
further down the road so it sounds like
he's going for a robert downey jr iron
man in hugh jackman wolverine situation
where he just keeps playing spider-man
for a long long time
so for everyone that wanted an adult
spider-man who was a little more
hardcore
tom holland will become that spider-man
eventually he'll literally just age up
through the mcu movies until he's
middle-aged spider-man
being senpai to the younger newer
avengers characters
number one the only other major cameos
that we know about right now in all the
upcoming spider-man spider-verse and
venom movies is a j
jonah jameson and there are rumors of
ozcorp and norman osborne
stuff happening soon it's sony there was
a report that during the morbius movie
tyrese's character wields this special
gauntlet weapon that he uses to fight
morbius with and supposedly the tech is
made by ozcorp and that's our first
major easter egg for a new version of
norman
osborne green goblin jk simmons did say
that he'd already filmed his next jj
cameo scene and that he had more cameos
left on his contract
so right now my early prediction for
that is that he'll just show up in
every single new spider-man related
movie in small scenes that just help
weave everything together with
continuity between spider-man far from
home
morbius venom 2 and then spider-man 3.
some of the morbius daily bugle easter
eggs seem like they're more tobey
maguire easter eggs so it's hard to say
if they're going for a multiverse
explainer or if they're just trying to
mislead us
but let me know in the comments if the
title of spider-man 3 really does
wind up being homesick what do you want
the title of spider-man 4
to be while you wait for everything
click here for my new marvel avengers
review
and click here for my new marvel shang
chi movie teaser in iron man easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!